hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm going
to be reviewing the second trailer for
chappie I love the first trailer and
talked a lot about it and I put it on my
top 10 most anticipated films of 2015
oh plug in that video why waste any more
time the deployment of the planet's
first robotic police units became the
focus of the world in 2016 Vinson borer
is a former soldier problem without
official intelligence is his whites are
unpredictable
the scouts creator Deon Wilson sees a
rich future what interest me is a
machine that can think and feel it is
operated by a thinking human thinking we
don't want it's expensive it's me and
it's angry the scouts are huge success
don't worry about these projects
this new kind of life woman when you've
stepped in the evolution
you are chappy yeah these good stories
Jimmy's gonna do anything you want to do
in your life you can do write poetry
have original ideas
the world was a big problem for me
thinking robot could be the end of
mankind burn it to ash a great danger
headed all the way now
I don't drive or do this you wanna
survive chappie you must fight
you think you're real
would be special
find consciousness
I am chippy
that is the most adorable action hero we
are ever going to have Wow both trailers
offered something different like the
first one really captured character and
heart you still got that in this trailer
but it they were still like hey we
didn't forget about intensity and bad
ask them going on here you know like it
kind of reminds me of iRobot this film
has been reminding me of a lot of things
Robocop wall-e now it sort of has an
iRobot vibe about it where there's a
bunch of different robots but then they
take this one robot it ends up thinking
and feeling in but chappie you know I'm
from my understanding is played by
sharlto copley Copley Coakley or
whatever he's [ __ ] awesome looks
amazing like he looks so real I'm
watching the trailer and I'm really
believing what's going on like the
designs of him are great the visuals the
performance looks awesome like I love
chappie that that's a plain and simple I
want to put my dick in Japanese that
simple the guy from Slumdog Millionaire
he looks like he has a performance in
America that is better than last
airbender film it's good that he's
getting his do finally Dev Patel I think
is his name or that guy from Slumdog
Millionaire as most people call him I
don't know why but something tells me
deaf Patel will die in this film because
he's that guy who like created chappie
and you know he probably has the closest
relationship with him and something
tells me he's gonna like it like there's
gonna be all is lost moment and he's
gonna be the thing that is lost at that
time Hugh Jackman looks great it's cool
to see him not playing a Wolverine type
of role again cuz you know like we get
one of those every other year and
whenever he comes out with a role that
is not that you know lame is prisoners
he's fantastic and he finally gets to
have his [ __ ] accent he never gets to
use his real voice I wonder if that'll
take away from this movie I like his
haircut - he looks like a dumbass with
it you immediately prefer chappie over
him because his hair just looks silly
but what I like about having Hugh
Jackman as like the villain essentially
he doesn't seem like a bad guy he seems
like someone who really does believe
he's doing the right thing like this is
about political point of view
and stuff so he seems like he's just
acting off what he knows is right I know
from the audience's perspective it's
probably gonna be more bias for Chafee
but still I feel like Hugh Jackman's not
playing the bad guy like he looks like
he's giving a full-on performance and I
really hope does get recognized if it is
successful I mean Chafee just there's
all those things that you want a robot
who learns how to think and if you'll do
like drawers and watches TV and reads
books cuz it's like oh oh you're doing
human being so it's adorable and
Sigourney Weaver best woman to bring in
to play a [ __ ] whether or not she is on
the good side or the bad side she tends
to be the head of it it is kind of a
[ __ ] and she is a [ __ ] it up once more
so excited for the one thing that
worried me about this trailer like
district 9 had it perfect
right Elysium I thought was really good
but I felt there were some things about
it that would kind of had some studio
touches on it a little too much because
the first trailer for chappie just
seemed like a really wonderful
experience this one's like oh no it's
gonna be jam-packed with action and
intensity I hope it's more like the
first trailer with like 30% of it being
like this trailer worth is really this
unless if it's a film that just really
gradually builds into it then yeah I
think it'll be a fantastic film like at
the end of the day I'm gonna go in with
an open mind and just see whatever the
director is going for if it's good or
not from what we're getting from the
footage I'm preferring more along lines
of the first trailer still like the
action I'm not talking about looks
[ __ ] amazing and Neill Blomkamp knows
how to do action really well what he
knows how to do really well and this is
why I'm not that concerned about it he
knows how to do like these great science
fiction tales that are like tales with
incredible character and really
meaningful action and just jaw-dropping
visuals I've never used that
jaw-dropping visuals that's that's like
something an [ __ ] says I am
consciousness as you do that I am
consciousness I am life I need a
megaphone
that's the next bein right there
chappies [ __ ] voice anyway guys thanks
for sign me that trailer was out and
it's like still one of them films I'm
like super jacked to see this year if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects where I
follow this part up with some type of
dumb joke Alfie Earnshaw hey Ryan you
are the greatest humans ever exist and
everywhere you should see step should be
known as your step you meant to put your
but he's a little illiterate your step
should be known as Holy Land and can I
get a shout out please Alfie Earnshaw
you have Earnshaw yourself a shout out
by saying these incredible words I am
probably the greatest human to ever
exist
it goes Ryan Gandhi Jesus
Tom Cruise and little right there we go
my penis my penis sir Alfie you're a
nice guy and you take care of little
Alfie for all of us
it may be one day little Alfie and
little Ryan will meet they won't want to
shake hands up cuz I don't do that if I
got a girlfriend now and she says no
even if it's with another guy it's still
cheating
whatever Veronica Tyson Sherbourne hey
Ryan
huge fan of you and your channel just
like you I review movies and trailers
and I would love if you gave me a shout
out love your vids keep it up Tyrone's
Sherbourne sure time to burn you Tyson
ha I already burned you because I called
you Tyrone when your name's Tyson that
wasn't a mistake I intentionally did
that you review movies and trailers and
you want a shout-out Oh Oh my
competition over here wants me to
promote him what do you think this is
some type of internet world where people
collab and help promote each other no
that's like Eastern culture beliefs of
kindness and stuff I don't I do this the
American Way and that is competition
good job on doing your movies and
trailer stuff that's awesome I mean we
could always use more of that if you
type the category in a movie critic on
YouTube you only get like 569 people so
we could use another one sure you kind
of look like one of the schmoes no guys
look where I'm gonna give you a few tips
to give the ladies okay
grow some facial hair and pump up that
chest see look at this I said hello
doing the booty bounce baby see Tyson
they'll like it do the boobie dance